- Bine ai revenit la „Înțelegerea Informației și Computației Cuantice." Mă numesc John Watrous și sunt Directorul Tehnic
pentru IBM Quantum Education.
Aceasta este a cincea lecție din serie și este prima lecție din
a doua unitate a seriei, care este despre Algoritmi Cuantici.
În această unitate, vom investiga
avantajele computaționale ale informației cuantice, adică vom arunca
o privire asupra a ceea ce putem face
cu calculatoare cuantice și avantajele pe care calculatoarele cuantice le-ar putea avea potențial
față de calculatoarele clasice.
Ne vom concentra pe ceea ce putem face cu un singur calculator cuantic, spre deosebire de un mediu distribuit,
de exemplu,
unde mai multe calculatoare cuantice interacționează printr-o rețea de un anumit tip.
Există, de fapt, avantaje cuantice de găsit în mediile distribuite, unde comunicarea și
criptografia intră în joc,
dar nu vom vorbi
despre aceste lucruri în această unitate.
Această unitate este despre algoritmi cuantici care rulează pe calculatoare cuantice individuale.
Să începem cu o întrebare firească. Ce avantaje ar putea oferi potențial un
calculator cuantic?
Principalul este că calculatoarele cuantice ar putea oferi soluții mai rapide la unele probleme computaționale.
Timpul este prețios, și deși calculatoarele pe care le
folosim zilnic sunt destul de rapide, tot sunt prea lente
pentru a rezolva anumite probleme computaționale tocmai din cauza dificultății
computaționale inerente a acelor probleme.
Acest potențial că calculatoarele cuantice ne-ar putea permite să rezolvăm probleme pentru care calculatoarele clasice
sunt prea lente
este ceea ce a impulsionat cu adevărat
cercetarea algoritmilor cuantici în ultimele câteva decenii.
Există și alte resurse computaționale
pe lângă timp care pot fi luate în considerare, cum ar fi cantitatea de memorie a calculatorului necesară pentru calcule,
dar calculatoarele cuantice nu pot
oferi prea multe economii în ceea ce privește memoria, după cum se dovedește, și memoria calculatoarelor clasice este destul de ieftină
în special comparativ cu memoria cuantică. Deci nu există
prea mult potențial aici.
Am putea, de asemenea, să ne gândim la alte resurse, cum ar fi cantitatea de energie
necesară pentru calcul, dar de fapt nu ai nevoie de multă energie deloc
pentru a calcula clasic, în special dacă ești
dispus să încetinești lucrurile.
Deci, cu adevărat, este timpul
necesar pentru calcule cel pe care ne concentrăm în principal.
Iată o prezentare generală a lecției, care este despre un
model specific de calcul cunoscut sub numele de modelul cu interogări.
Poți să te gândești la acest model ca la un fel de vas Petri pentru dezvoltarea ideilor algoritmice, atât cuantice, cât și clasice.
Nu este menit să fie un model practic care să descrie tipurile
de probleme computaționale pe care le întâlnim în viața reală.
Ne vom îndepărta de modelul cu interogări în lecțiile ulterioare ale acestei unități și ne vom concentra în schimb pe modele motivate de noțiuni de calcul mai practice,
dar modelul cu interogări este un
loc foarte bun de unde să începem.
Este un model simplu care ne permite să explorăm
potențialul calculatoarelor cuantice fără ca o mulțime de detalii tehnice
să stea în cale,
și ne permite, de asemenea, să izolăm unele dintre
ideile cu adevărat importante din spatele computației cuantice și modul în care funcționează.
Computația cuantică s-a dezvoltat, de fapt, mai întâi în cadrul acestui model, iar ideile care au
fost dezvoltate în el au inspirat foarte direct
algoritmi cuantici importanți
precum algoritmul lui Shor pentru factorizare.
În prima secțiune a lecției, vom arunca o privire mai atentă la ce anume este modelul de calcul cu interogări,
și în a doua, a treia
și a patra secțiune, vom discuta trei
algoritmi cuantici cu interogări, și anume algoritmul lui Deutsch,
algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa
și algoritmul lui Simon, care dezvăluie avantaje din ce în ce mai
impresionante
ale calculatoarelor cuantice
față de calculatoarele clasice în cadrul modelului de calcul cu interogări.
Pentru a explica modelul de calcul cu interogări, să începem mai întâi cu o
abstracție mai standard a calculului.
Iată o imagine care
reprezintă un calcul în termeni foarte simpli și de bază.
Avem un input, care de obicei ia
forma unui șir binar, deși am putea folosi alte
simboluri dacă am dori.
Inputul este furnizat calculului, care este reprezentat de un
dreptunghi albastru în această imagine,
și rezultatul calculului este că un anumit output este produs, și din nou, acesta este cel mai
frecvent un șir binar.
Desigur, această imagine
nu este deloc specifică cu privire la modul în care funcționează calculul în sine.
Putem formula diferite
modele computaționale specifice pentru a face asta, cum ar fi mașinile Turing
și circuit-ul Boolean,
sau quantum circuits dacă ne gândim la
computația cuantică.
Este adevărat că această imagine
nu reprezintă faptul că multe dintre
calculatoarele pe care le folosim zilnic primesc continuu
input și produc output,
interacționând practic cu noi și cu alte calculatoare prin
internet, de exemplu.
Dar nu încercăm să reprezentăm
acele interacțiuni aici.
Acesta este despre modelarea
sarcinilor computaționale izolate.
De exemplu, inputul ar putea fi codificarea
binară a unui număr sau o reprezentare a unei matrice
WEBVTT
sau o descriere a unei molecule sau orice altceva avem în minte, și există o sarcină computațională
care se efectuează pe acel input singur.
Punctul cheie de reținut este
că întregul input este furnizat calculului, și nimic din
input nu îi este ascuns.
Modelul de calcul cu interogări
funcționează diferit.
În modelul cu interogări, inputul este pus la dispoziție
sub forma unei funcții pe care calculul o poate
accesa făcând interogări,
sau cu alte cuvinte, evaluând funcția
pe inputuri diferite.
Aici poți vedea asta reprezentat
sub forma unei imagini.
Similar cu ce am văzut înainte, calculul este reprezentat
de un dreptunghi albastru, dar în loc să primească un input direct
sub forma unui șir
de biți, de exemplu, accesează inputul punând efectiv întrebări
și primind răspunsuri.
Uneori folosim
termenii oracle și cutie neagră pentru a ne referi la mecanismul
care furnizează inputul.
Există o distincție între
un oracle și o cutie neagră în teoria complexității, dar asta nu va fi deloc relevant în scopurile acestei discuții.
Oricum, acești termeni sunt meniti
să transmită ideea de bază.
În Grecia Antică, puteai
să mergi la un oracle, cum ar fi Oracolul de la Delfi,
și să pui o întrebare importantă,
și oracolul ar răspunde
la acea întrebare specifică, dar cu siguranță nu ți-ar spune tot ce știa.
Pe aceeași linie, când
ne gândim la o cutie neagră, avem în minte un anumit
fel de proces sau sistem
unde putem alege ce intră și putem vedea ce iese, dar nu avem nicio înțelegere
a funcționării sale interne.
Și asta este cazul de față. Inputul pentru problemă
ia forma unei funcții, și tot ce putem face este
să evaluăm acea funcție,
dar altfel, nu avem
nicio cunoaștere sau înțelegere despre modul în care funcționează.
Pe parcursul lecției,
vom rezerva litera f pentru funcția care
reprezintă inputul, și vom face ipoteza
că aceasta ia întotdeauna
forma pe care o vezi chiar aici.
Sigma denotă alfabetul binar, deci f este o funcție de la șiruri
de biți la șiruri de biți,
și specific, vom
presupune că inputul lui f este un șir de biți de lungime n, iar outputul este un șir
de biți de lungime m,
unde n și m sunt numere întregi pozitive.
Pentru diferite probleme, vom
avea restricții asupra lui n și m, dar în toate cazurile, funcția de input va
lua o formă ca aceasta.
Când spunem că un
calcul face o interogare, înțelegem că
funcția f este evaluată o dată,
adică un șir oarecare x de lungime N este selectat de calcul, iar șirul f(x) este
apoi pus la dispoziția sa
de oracle sau de cutia neagră. Și în final, modul foarte simplu în care vom măsura costul computațional
al unui algoritm cu interogări este să numărăm câte interogări necesită.
Deci, deși este adevărat că
ne interesează cel mai mult cât durează calculele, când studiem modelul cu interogări,
în general păstrăm lucrurile
simple și numărăm doar interogările, și asta vom face în această lecție.
Acum, să aruncăm o privire la câteva
exemple de probleme cu interogări, adică probleme computaționale în modelul cu interogări,
și aici, apropo, voi descrie doar
problemele în sine, și în acest punct nu voi spune nimic
despre cum să le rezolv.
Prima problemă este problema SAU.
În acest caz, inputul este o funcție
de la n biți la doar 1 bit, deci m este egal cu 1 pentru această problemă,
și outputul cerut pentru
problemă este fie 1, fie 0.
Dacă există un șir x de n biți pentru care f(x) este egal cu 1, atunci răspunsul corect este 1,
și altfel, dacă f(x) este
întotdeauna 0 pentru orice șir x, atunci răspunsul corect este 0.
Deci dacă ne gândim la funcția f ca furnizând acces aleator la doi la puterea n biți, câte unul pentru fiecare șir x de n biți,
atunci ceea ce aceasta cere
este SAU-ul acelor biți, și de aceea se numește problema SAU.
Un alt exemplu este problema parității, care este similară cu problema SAU, cu excepția că cere paritatea,
sau cu alte cuvinte, SAU-ul exclusiv al tuturor valorilor de output de
un singur bit ale funcției.
Un alt mod de a spune asta este
că răspunsul corect este 0 dacă numărul de șiruri x de n biți pentru care f(x) este egal cu 1 este par,
și răspunsul corect este
1 dacă acel număr este impar.
Un exemplu de problemă în care m nu este neapărat egal cu 1 este problema minimului.
Aici, funcția f ia forma obișnuită, și nu există restricții pentru n și m,
și răspunsul corect este indiferent ce valoare de output
a funcției apare prima în ordinea lexicografică
sau de dicționar
a șirurilor binare. Alternativ, dacă vrei
să te gândești la șirurile de lungime m ca reprezentând numere întregi nenegative în notație binară,
atunci răspunsul corect
este cea mai mică valoare posibilă sau minimă care
iese din această funcție.
WEBVTT
Uneori luăm în considerare și probleme cu interogări unde avem o promisiune
privind funcția de input, sau cu alte cuvinte, un anumit
fel de garanție pentru aceasta,
și nu ne preocupăm de funcțiile care nu îndeplinesc acea promisiune.
Funcțiile care nu satisfac promisiunea sunt considerate inputuri „don't care".
Și nu suntem responsabili pentru ce se întâmplă pe acele inputuri.
Iată un exemplu de problemă cu interogări cu promisiune, numită căutare unică.
Este legată de problema SAU,
dar este diferită.
Funcția de input are aceeași
formă ca pentru problema SAU, adică mapează
șiruri de n biți la biți.
De data aceasta, ni se promite că
există exact un șir Z care face ca f să se evalueze la 1,
cu f(x) egal cu 0
pentru orice șir x în afară de z, și outputul corect
este acest șir unic z.
Desigur, există
alegeri pentru funcția f care nu satisfac această condiție, dar nu impunem nicio cerință deloc
algoritmilor pentru această problemă când le sunt date astfel de
funcții ca input.
Ne interesează doar funcțiile care satisfac promisiunea.
Acum, toate cele patru
probleme pe care tocmai le-am menționat sunt probleme destul de naturale, în sensul că sunt ușor de explicat,
și este ușor să ne imaginăm situații în care ar putea apărea nevoia de a le rezolva, dar unele probleme cu interogări
nu sunt deloc așa.
De fapt, uneori considerăm probleme cu interogări
foarte contrivite, unde este dificil să ne imaginăm că cineva ar vrea vreodată
să le rezolve în practică.
Problema lui Simon, pe care o
vom vedea mai târziu în lecție, cade cumva în această categorie, dar există și altele
care sunt mult mai rele în anumit sens, dar care, cu toate acestea, se dovedesc a fi destul de importante pentru studiul modelului cu interogări.
Nu studiem aceste probleme pentru că vrem neapărat
să le rezolvăm în practică.
Poți să te gândești la asta astfel: căutăm
extreme de diferite feluri,
în special când lucrăm în cadrul
acestui vas Petri al unui model, o modalitate firească de a explora
idei algoritmice cuantice
este să formulăm probleme foarte contrivite, unde putem exploata cel mai bine
puterea calculatoarelor cuantice.
Și asta poate arunca de fapt
multă lumină asupra modului în care calculatoarele cuantice
pot fi potențial utile în medii mai practice.
Putem formaliza noțiunea
de interogare în moduri diferite, în funcție de modelul computațional
cu care lucrăm.
De exemplu, în modelul mașinii
Turing de calcul, despre care nu am vorbit și nu vom intra în el în această serie,
există un anumit mod de
a formaliza noțiunea de interogare care are sens pentru acel model.
Pentru modelele de circuit, definim tipuri speciale de
gate-uri numite gate-uri de interogare, și astfel sunt reprezentate formal interogările.
Pentru circuit-urile Boolean, există o modalitate foarte simplă de a face asta, care este pur și simplu să ne imaginăm
că avem gate-uri de interogare
care evaluează funcția de input direct, cum poți vedea pe ecran.
Ideea este că putem
folosi aceste gate-uri de interogare pentru a construi circuit-uri care rezolvă orice
problemă la care lucrăm,
și pentru a funcționa corect, circuit-urile trebuie să dea răspunsul corect pentru orice funcție de input f este dată,
presupunând că îndeplinește promisiunea în cazul unei probleme cu promisiune.
Iată un exemplu simplu
al unui circuit Boolean care rezolvă problema
parității când n este egal cu 1,
deci funcția de input f este de la
1 bit la 1 bit în acest caz.
Ceea ce face acest circuit este să evalueze funcția
f pe inputurile 0 și 1 folosind aceste două gate-uri de interogare.
Apoi conectează cele două valori de output pe care le
obține de la gate-urile de interogare în circuit-ul Boolean din lecția trei care calculează XOR-ul,
care este același lucru cu paritatea.
Pentru a fi clar, aceste două
valori de input chiar aici nu sunt inputuri în problemă,
adică în problema parității,
când lucrăm cu modelul cu interogări, inputul în problemă
este funcția f, și ar trebui să te gândești la aceste
două inputuri în circuit
ca valori codificate rigid
care nu se schimbă niciodată, ele fac parte esențialmente din algoritm.
Vrem să calculăm XOR-ul lui f(0) și f(1), deci am inițializat aceste
două fire în acest mod
pentru a funcționa. Am folosit două gate-uri de interogare
aici, acesta și acesta,
și deci algoritmul reprezentat
de acest circuit Boolean face două interogări, și dacă ne gândim la problema
parității pentru un moment
pentru funcții de la un bit la un bit, vedem că este absolut necesar pentru orice circuit Boolean
care rezolvă această problemă
să facă cel puțin două interogări.
Dacă faci doar o singură interogare, astfel încât cunoști o singură
valoare de output a funcției f și nu pe cealaltă, de fapt nu ai
nicio informație
despre paritate, deoarece cealaltă valoare de output
ar putea fi la fel de bine 0 sau 1, conducând la oricare dintre cele
două soluții posibile
ale problemei. Deci în ceea ce privește numărul
de interogări pe care le face, acest circuit Boolean este pe cât de bun se poate
pentru problema parității
când n este egal cu 1.
WEBVTT
Mai există un aspect despre gate-urile de interogare care merită menționat înainte să continuăm, și anume că atunci când proiectăm și analizăm algoritmi cu interogări,
nu ne preocupăm deloc de modul în care
gate-urile de interogare sunt implementate.
Se presupune că aceste
gate-uri de interogare ne sunt date, iar dificultatea de a le construi
nu este preocuparea noastră.
Poți să te gândești la
gate-urile de interogare în sine ca la input dacă vrei, și nu este treaba noastră să creăm inputul, încercăm doar să
rezolvăm o anumită problemă
dat inputul. Desigur, când f este o funcție
de la un bit la un bit, există doar patru alegeri posibile,
și ar fi suficient de ușor
să implementăm oricare dintre ele, dar în general, pentru funcții
cu mulți biți de input,
ar putea fi extrem de dificil să implementăm gate-uri de interogare
pentru acele funcții.
Pentru a fi clar, asta nu
înseamnă că problema modului în care gate-urile de interogare sunt
implementate nu este importantă, ci mai degrabă că nu este considerată
ca parte a costului
unui algoritm cu interogări.
Asta este consistent cu ideea că nu este vorba cu adevărat
despre calcul practic sau despre construirea efectivă a circuit-urilor în sine,
ci despre lucrul în cadrul
unui cadru teoretic care ne spune lucruri interesante
despre calcul.
Vom mai spune despre asta când vom face saltul de la acest model la un model mai standard de calcul, și asta este în principal ceea ce lecția următoare,
Lecția 6, va trata.
Acum să ne îndreptăm atenția
spre quantum circuits.
Pentru quantum circuits, vom schimba
definiția gate-urilor de interogare pentru a le face unitare.
Vrem să putem face
interogări în cadrul quantum circuits și ca acestea să opereze
liniar pe stări cuantice
astfel încât să putem face eficient
interogări în superpoziție.
S-ar putea părea că mutăm
stâlpii porții, ca să spunem așa, schimbând ce înțelegem prin interogare față de ce am văzut tocmai
pentru circuit-uri Boolean,
dar există o justificare pentru asta pe care o vom discuta în mai
multe detalii în lecția următoare.
Deocamdată, este doar o definiție.
Mai concret, definiția
este următoarea: dată orice funcție f de
aceeași formă ca înainte,
adică care mapează șiruri de n biți
la șiruri de m biți, gate-ul de interogare Uf acționează pe n + m qubits
și este definit prin
acțiunea descrisă aici pe stările bazei standard.
Vom vedea o figură
reprezentând această definiție imediat, dar mai întâi, permite-mi să clarific notația
care este folosită aici,
și anume că ori de câte ori
folosim simbolul XOR ca operație între două
șiruri de aceeași lungime,
ne referim la
SAU exclusiv bit cu bit, și iată un exemplu.
În definiție, avem că atât y cât și f(x) sunt
șiruri de lungime m, deci acest șir de chiar acolo
reprezintă șirul pe care îl obținem
aplicând XOR pe cele două șiruri
împreună, un bit odată, și iată diagrama
care explică cum funcționează aceste gate-uri.
Primele n qubits corespund
argumentului funcției.
Și când încep
într-o stare a bazei standard, ket x în această diagramă, acea stare a bazei standard
trece neschimbată
și este ecouată ca parte a outputului.
Ultimele m qubits corespund outputului
funcției f, și când încep în
orice stare a bazei standard,
ket y în această diagramă, ceea ce se întâmplă este că
outputul funcției f(x) este aplicat XOR pe șirul y.
Asta se întâmplă pentru
stările bazei standard, și dacă vrem să știm
ce se întâmplă în general pentru alte stări cuantice,
folosim liniaritatea, cum facem întotdeauna.
Un motiv pentru a defini gate-urile de interogare astfel, unde ecouăm inputul și folosim XOR-ul bit cu bit pentru output
este că aceste gate-uri sunt întotdeauna unitare pentru orice alegere a funcției f.
Aceasta este, de fapt, o
operație deterministă.
Și dacă ar trebui să o exprimăm ca matrice pentru orice alegere a unei funcții F, am obține o matrice de permutare,
adică una cu un singur 1 în fiecare rând și în fiecare coloană, și toate celelalte intrări egale cu 0.
Iar matricele de permutare
sunt întotdeauna unitare.
De fapt, pentru această operație, vom obține că operația
este propriul ei invers, deci Uf dagger este egal cu Uf.
Dacă tot ce vrem să facem cu aceste
gate-uri este să evaluăm f(x) pentru un anumit șir x, este ușor,
putem seta pur și simplu y
ca șirul format numai din zerouri. Deci când aplicăm XOR pe biții lui y, obținem doar f(x).
Iată, apropo, notația folosită pentru a denota șirul format numai din zerouri.
Arată ca 0 la puterea M, dar nu asta înseamnă.
Înseamnă șirul de zerouri
cu lungimea egală cu M.
Când vorbim despre
șiruri spre deosebire de numere, exponenții înseamnă de obicei că repetăm acel șir
de un anumit număr de ori,
deci acesta este 0 repetat de m ori.
WEBVTT
Este doar un mod convenabil și precis de a descrie acest șir.
Din nou, când
lucrăm cu modelul cu interogări, nu ne preocupăm de modul în care
implementăm aceste gate-uri de interogare.
Aceasta este aceeași problemă
pe care am avut-o cu gate-urile de interogare pentru circuit-ul Boolean.
Nu este treaba noastră să pregătim inputul, ne este dat inputul sub
forma acestor gate-uri de interogare.
Voi sublinia totuși că, dacă știm cum să
implementăm funcția f folosind un circuit Boolean, atunci este posibil să
translatem acea implementare
destul de direct la o implementare cu
quantum circuit a lui Uf, și vom vedea exact cum
funcționează asta în lecția următoare.
Incidental, este destul de simplu să creezi un circuit Boolean
care funcționează astfel, folosind un singur
gate de interogare clasic pentru funcția f,
dar asta este destul de diferit de a avea o implementare cu
quantum circuit a acestui gate unitar.
Punctul este totuși că
pentru algoritmii clasici cu interogări, a avea un gate de interogare care funcționează astfel este, de fapt, echivalent
cu a avea un
gate de interogare clasic obișnuit pentru f, în sensul că oricare dintre ele poate fi implementat folosind pe celălalt.
În această secțiune a lecției, vom discuta algoritmul lui Deutsch, care este un algoritm cuantic cu interogări foarte simplu, dar este cu adevărat o bijuterie.
Acest algoritm provine dintr-un articol din 1985 scris de David Deutsch, care a fost unul dintre primii oameni care a lucrat la fundamentele teoretice
ale computației cuantice.
Algoritmul în sine reprezintă o parte foarte mică
din articolul lui Deutsch din 1985, și de fapt,
algoritmul pe care îl numim acum
algoritmul lui Deutsch este de fapt o versiune îmbunătățită a algoritmului pe care Deutsch l-a descris.
Oferă un exemplu foarte modest al modului în care calculatoarele cuantice pot
oferi avantaje computaționale, dar trebuie să începi de undeva,
și a fost cu adevărat o scânteie importantă care a pus lucrurile în mișcare.
Algoritmul lui Deutsch rezolvă o problemă cu interogări care este adesea numită problema lui Deutsch în contextul computației cuantice,
dar de fapt, nu este altceva
decât problema parității pentru funcții de la un bit la un bit, despre care am vorbit deja.
Cum am văzut deja, există patru funcții
de la un bit la un bit, și sunt descrise aici pe ecran prin tabelele lor de valori.
Prima și ultima dintre aceste
funcții sunt constante, în timp ce cele două din mijloc sunt echilibrate în sensul că cele două
valori de output posibile
apar același număr de ori.
Pentru cele două funcții constante,
vedem că paritatea, sau cu alte cuvinte, SAU-ul exclusiv al celor două outputuri este 0,
și pentru cele două funcții echilibrate, paritatea outputurilor este 1.
Deci un mod echivalent de
a descrie problema parității în acest caz particular, unde funcția f ia
un singur bit ca input,
sau cu alte cuvinte, problema lui Deutsch, este cum vezi aici.
Inputul este o funcție f
de la un bit la un bit, și outputul este 0 dacă f este constantă
și 1 dacă f este echilibrată.
Cum am sugerat deja, orice algoritm clasic cu interogări
care rezolvă această problemă trebuie să facă cel puțin două interogări la f.
Dacă afli doar una din
cele două valori de output ale lui f, tot nu ai nicio informație despre paritatea celor două outputuri.
Și asta, apropo, este valabil
chiar și pentru algoritmii clasici care folosesc aleatoriu.
Aleatoriul poate fi uneori foarte util pentru rezolvarea problemelor cu interogări, și vom vedea un exemplu
un pic mai târziu în lecție,
dar aleatoriul nu ajută aici.
Deci algoritmul nostru de dinainte este optim dintre algoritmii clasici cu interogări
pentru problema lui Deutsch.
Acum vom arunca o privire
la algoritmul lui Deutsch, care este un algoritm cuantic cu interogări ce rezolvă problema lui Deutsch
folosind o singură interogare.
Și iată algoritmul
descris ca un quantum circuit.
Avem doi qubits
inițializați cum vezi aici, cu cel de sus inițializat la ket 0 și cel de jos inițializat la ket 1,
și vom vedea de ce inițializăm acești qubits astfel în scurt timp.
Efectuăm gate-uri Hadamard
pe cei doi qubits, îi alimentăm în gate-ul de interogare, efectuăm un alt gate
Hadamard pe qubit-ul de sus,
și apoi îl măsurăm. Și afirmația este că
rezultatul măsurătorii ne dă, cu certitudine, răspunsul
corect la problemă.
Deci să analizăm
circuit-ul pas cu pas pentru a vedea exact cum funcționează.
Starea celor doi qubits după primul strat de gate-uri Hadamard este produsul tensorial al
stărilor minus și plus.
Hadamard de sus mapează
starea 0 la o stare plus, iar Hadamard de jos mapează starea 1 la o stare minus.
Qubit-ul de sus este în dreapta, iar qubit-ul de jos este în stânga, deci aceasta este starea pe care o obținem.
Este foarte important ca qubit-ul de jos să fie într-o stare minus, apropo, asta nu ar funcționa dacă am
inițializa qubit-ul de jos
la o stare 0 în loc de o stare 1.
Vom extinde această stare
la jumătate, cum vezi aici.
Motivul pentru a face asta
nu este clar în acest punct, dar va fi convenabil
imediat.
În continuare, să ne gândim la
starea celor doi qubits după ce gate-ul de interogare este efectuat.
Modul în care funcționează gate-ul de interogare
este că calculează F pe starea bazei standard
a qubit-ului de sus și aplică XOR valorii
pe qubit-ul de jos,
WEBVTT
și iată putem vedea
rezultatul care apare.
Pentru primul termen, starea bazei standard
a qubit-ului de sus este 0, deci f(0) este aplicat XOR
pe qubit-ul de jos,
și asta funcționează prin liniaritate. Și este similar pentru al doilea termen, cu excepția că starea bazei standard
pentru qubit-ul de sus este 1, deci aplicăm XOR cu f(1) pe qubit-ul de jos.
Și în acest punct, putem
simplifica această expresie observând formula
pe care o poți vedea mai jos, care funcționează când a este fie 0, fie 1.
Și putem verifica pur și simplu asta pentru acele două valori separat.
Dacă a este egal cu 0, atunci
aplicarea XOR cu a nu face nimic, iar -1 la puterea 0 este 1,
deci cele două laturi sunt egale. Și dacă a este egal cu 1, obținem ket 1 minus ket
0 când aplicăm XOR,
care este negativ 1
înmulțit cu ket 0 minus ket 1.
Și dacă folosim acea formulă
pentru a simplifica starea noastră, unde luăm a egal
cu f(0) în stânga și a egal cu f(1) în dreapta,
obținem expresia
pe care o vezi chiar aici.
Deci când comparăm cele două
vectori de stare cuantică π1 și π2, vedem că ceea ce face gate-ul Uf
este efectiv să pună
una din cele două valori, f(0) sau f(1), în
exponentul lui -1,
sau cu alte cuvinte, în
faza fiecărui termen.
Acesta este motivul pentru
inițializarea qubit-ului de jos la 1 și efectuarea unui gate Hadamard pe el pentru a crea starea minus,
ceea ce permite să se întâmple asta.
Se numește fenomenul phase kickback, și vom reveni la el în câteva momente pentru a-l privi dintr-un alt unghi.
Este destul de important, și îl vom vedea
de câteva ori în lecție, precum și în lecțiile ulterioare.
Putem acum simplifica scoțând
starea minus afară pentru a obține expresia
pe care o vezi chiar aici.
Incidental, este
interesant să observi că de fapt nu există
nicio entanglement aici.
Ambele aceste stări sunt stări produs. Deci, deși entanglement-ul
este extrem de interesant,
nu se întâmplă să
joace niciun rol în acest algoritm particular.
Să curățăm un pic pentru a ne face mai mult spațiu.
Ceea ce putem face acum este să
scoatem un factor de -1 ridicat la puterea f(0) afară
pentru a obține expresia stării
pe care o vezi chiar aici.
Vei observa că chiar acolo avem SAU exclusiv al lui f(0) și f(1) în exponentul lui -1.
Ne-am putea aștepta ca asta să fie
f(1) minus f(0) deoarece scoatem factorul de -1 la puterea f(0) afară,
dar obținem aceeași
valoare dacă luăm XOR-ul deoarece acestea sunt biți, și singurul lucru care contează când avem un număr întreg în
exponentul lui -1
este dacă acel număr întreg este par sau impar.
Un alt mod de a exprima această
stare este cum avem aici, unde considerăm pur și simplu
cele două cazuri posibile pentru XOR.
Și acesta este un mod convenabil
de a exprima starea pe măsură ce considerăm acțiunea
ultimului gate Hadamard împreună cu măsurătoarea.
Când efectuăm ultimul
gate Hadamard pe qubit-ul de sus, starea plus este
transformată într-o stare 0
și starea minus este
transformată într-o stare 1, pe care o putem scrie mai
succint astfel.
Și în final, când
se efectuează măsurătoarea, rezultatul pe care îl obținem este
deci XOR-ul lui f(0) și f(1),
care este valoarea pe care o căutăm, și cam asta este cum funcționează algoritmul lui Deutsch.
Este destul de simplu, și dacă ne întrebăm ce
îl face să funcționeze, permițându-ne să calculăm
paritatea a doi biți
cu o singură interogare în loc de două, un răspuns rezonabil este
că este interferența.
Efectiv
calculăm f(0) și f(1) în același timp, deoarece mai întâi am efectuat
gate-ul Hadamard
pe qubit-ul de sus pentru a pune inputul în f într-o
superpoziție de 0 și 1.
Și prin intermediul phase kickback împreună cu ultimul gate Hadamard, creăm esențialmente interferență constructivă
pentru răspunsul corect și interferență destructivă
pentru răspunsul greșit.
Deci nu vedem răspunsul greșit, vedem doar răspunsul corect.
Permite-mi acum să spun un pic mai mult despre fenomenul phase kickback pentru a-l vedea dintr-un
unghi ușor diferit.
Mai întâi, să observăm
această formulă foarte simplă unde b și c sunt valori binare arbitrare.
Pe scurt, aplicarea XOR unui bit b cu valoarea 1 este același lucru cu efectuarea unui gate NOT sau a unei operații x pe b,
și desigur, aplicarea XOR
unui bit b cu valoarea 0 nu face nimic, ceea ce este același lucru cu efectuarea
operației identitate pe el.
Și putem exprima operația identitate ca x la puterea 0.
Deci dacă efectuăm un gate Uf pe doi qubits în starea bazei standard ket b tensorial ket a,
obținem acest rezultat, chiar prin definiția gate-ului Uf.
WEBVTT
și folosind formula, putem scrie alternativ acea stare cum vezi chiar aici.
Această formulă funcționează pentru toate alegerile lui b, deci prin liniaritate, funcționează
pentru o stare arbitrară SI
în locul ket-ului b.
Și în special, dacă vrem, putem alege SI ca starea minus.
Și iată cheia pentru a înțelege de ce se produce fenomenul phase kickback.
Este pentru că operația x
aplicată stării minus ne dă -1 înmulțit cu starea minus.
În termeni matematici, spunem că starea minus
este un eigenvector al operației x, cu valoarea proprie egală cu -1.
Eigenvectorii și valorile proprii
sunt critic importanți în algebra liniară, precum
și în informația cuantică, și vom mai
spune mult despre ei
pe măsură ce seria continuă.
Dar deocamdată, tot ce avem nevoie
este această formulă simplă.
Și folosind-o, putem
simplifica vectorul nostru de stare.
Și acela chiar acolo este esențialmente fenomenul phase kickback scris ca formulă.
Funcționează deoarece starea minus
este un eigenvector al operației NOT cu
valoarea proprie -1.
Vom generaliza asta în mod
destul de major în Lecția 7, când ne vom întoarce la procedura de estimare a fazei, care este ceea ce conduce
algoritmul de factorizare al lui Shor.
Putem vedea această formulă în acțiune în analiza algoritmului lui Deutsch
după cum urmează.
Înainte de gate-ul de interogare, starea noastră este produsul tensorial al stărilor minus și plus.
Aplicăm apoi gate-ul de interogare, și expandând starea plus
ne dă această stare.
Acum aplicăm formula phase kickback pentru a obține această expresie, și apoi analiza
continuă ca înainte.
Este la fel ca înainte, dar aici ne concentrăm pur și simplu
pe phase kickback pentru a-l putea recunoaște
și a fi pregătiți
când apare din nou.
În continuare, ne vom întoarce la
algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa, care este o extensie
a algoritmului lui Deutsch ce rezolvă de fapt câteva
diferite probleme cu interogări.
Avantajul pe care
algoritmul lui Deutsch îl oferă față de algoritmii clasici
este destul de modest, o interogare față de două.
Algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa mărește oarecum acel avantaj, și voi explica ce înțeleg
prin asta când ajungem acolo.
Algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa poate fi privit ca o modalitate naturală și directă de a extinde algoritmul lui Deutsch
de la funcții de la un bit la un bit la funcții de la n biți la un bit, sau cu alte cuvinte, funcții de această formă.
Ca quantum circuit, algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa
arată astfel, și mă voi referi la asta ca la circuit-ul Deutsch-Jozsa
doar pentru a face o distincție minoră
între acest circuit și algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa în sine, deoarece există și un
pas de post-procesare clasic.
Ideea este că dacă rulăm
acest circuit și apoi măsurăm, vom obține un șir y de n biți
care ne spune ceva
despre funcția f.
În acest punct, apropo, nu am spus de fapt
care este problema cu interogări pe care sperăm să
o rezolvăm cu acest circuit, asta vine foarte curând.
Dar ideea este că
rulând acest circuit, vom obține informații despre f care pot ajuta potențial
la rezolvarea problemelor cu interogări
unde f este inputul. Și cum am spus adineauri, putem folosi de fapt acest circuit
pentru a rezolva câteva
diferite probleme cu interogări.
Mai întâi, să aruncăm o privire
la problema cu interogări cunoscutî ca problema Deutsch-Jozsa, care este problema pe care
circuit-ul Deutsch-Jozsa
a fost inițial menit să o rezolve.
Problema Deutsch-Jozsa este o generalizare a problemei lui Deutsch, unde scopul este să determini dacă o funcție dată
este constantă sau echilibrată.
Observă că aceasta nu este modalitatea naturală de a generaliza problema parității
pentru funcții de această formă.
Aici nu calculăm paritatea, sarcina este să outputăm 0 dacă
funcția f este constantă
și 1 dacă funcția f este echilibrată.
Primul lucru de observat despre
această problemă este că atunci când n, numărul de biți de input ai
funcției f, este cel puțin 2,
există alegeri pentru funcție care nu sunt nici constante, nici echilibrate.
De exemplu, iată o
funcție de la 2 biți la 1 bit care nu este nici constantă, nici echilibrată.
Nu este constantă deoarece ambele valori binare
apar printre outputuri, și nu este echilibrată
deoarece cele două valori de output
apar cu frecvențe diferite. 0 apare de trei ori
și 1 apare doar o dată.
Pentru a fi echilibrată,
outputurile 0 și 1 trebuie să apară exact
același număr de ori.
Faptul că există funcții care nu sunt nici constante, nici echilibrate când n este cel puțin 2 este în regulă totuși, vom considera pur și simplu funcțiile de acest fel
ca inputuri „don't care". Deci cu alte cuvinte, aceasta
este o problemă cu promisiune.
Și iată o declarație precisă
a problemei.
WEBVTT
Ni se promite că funcția de input f este fie constantă, fie echilibrată, iar scopul este să aflăm
care dintre ele este.
Și nu suntem responsabili pentru ce se întâmplă dacă inputul
nu îndeplinește promisiunea.
Algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa,
care rezolvă această problemă, constă mai întâi în rularea circuit-ului Deutsch-Jozsa și apoi outputarea lui 0
dacă șirul pe care îl
obținem din măsurători este șirul format numai din zerouri
și outputarea lui 1 altfel.
Un alt mod de a spune asta este că outputăm SAU-ul
biților pe care îi măsurăm.
Pentru a analiza algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa, va fi util să
ne luăm câteva momente să gândim la gate-urile Hadamard.
Putem, desigur, descrie operația Hadamard
ca matrice, dar o putem descrie și
în termeni ai acțiunii sale
pe stările bazei standard,
cum vezi chiar acolo.
Aceste două ecuații pot fi
combinate într-o singură ecuație, care descrie cum
funcționează o operație Hadamard pentru a luând oricare dintre
cele două valori binare,
și putem merge un pic mai departe și exprima ceea ce
obținem ca o sumă astfel.
Folosind acea formulă, putem veni cu o formulă care descrie modul în care funcționează un strat
de gate-uri Hadamard, unde aplicăm un gate Hadamard
fiecăruia dintre n qubits.
Iată descriem această
acțiune pe stările bazei standard.
Și pentru a fi clar cu privire la notație, când scriem h la puterea n astfel, unde n la puterea este un superscript,
înțelegem produsul tensorial
de n ori al lui H cu el însuși, sau cu alte cuvinte, n copii
ale lui h toate produse tensorial.
Aplicăm această operație
pe o stare a bazei standard, și urmez
convenția pe care o folosește Qiskit
pentru a indexa șirurile binare, deoarece este un moment bun
să introduc acea convenție.
Deci x0 este un bit, x1 este un bit,
și așa mai departe cu n biți în total, iar biții sunt ordonați cum
îi vezi pe ecran.
Poți să te gândești la acest
mod de indexare a biților ca la corespunzătorul semnificației lor dacă privim șirurile ca
reprezentând numere întregi
în notație binară, de exemplu.
Dacă aplicăm un gate Hadamard
fiecăruia dintre acești qubits, putem exprima alternativ rezultatul ca produsul tensorial de n ori
al unui gate Hadamard aplicat fiecărui qubit, și apoi putem aplica formula noastră fiecăruia dintre factorii tensoriali.
Și folosim
numele y și -1 până la y1 în locul lui b în formulă,
deci acestea sunt valori binare. Și ne asigurăm să folosim un nume nou de fiecare dată când folosim formula.
Dacă apoi expandăm totul folosind multiliniaritatea
produselor tensoriale, obținem expresia
pe care o vezi chiar acolo.
Și pentru a fi clar, cele n sume sunt
combinate într-o singură sumă, dar tot sumăm
peste toate valorile posibile
pentru valorile binare individuale.
Acum să curățăm lucrurile pentru a putea merge un pic mai departe.
Și pasul următor este să
introducem o nouă operație pe șiruri numită produsul punctual binar.
Aceasta este o operație pe șiruri binare de aceeași lungime.
Și produsul punctual binar al două șiruri x și y
de aceeași lungime este SAU exclusiv sau paritatea
produselor biților individuali.
Ai putea spune, de asemenea, că este XOR-ul ȘI-ului logic al biților individuali, deoarece ȘI este același lucru cu produsul
pentru valori binare. Un alt mod de a-l descrie
este că este 1 sau 0
în funcție de dacă
suma produselor biților individuali este impară sau pară.
Este foarte asemănător cu un produs interior dacă ne gândim la șiruri
ca vectori de valori binare, dar unde calculăm modulo 2,
sau cu alte cuvinte, luăm restul după împărțirea la 2.
Nu este chiar un produs interior, deci merită un alt nume.
În cazul nostru, putem folosi produsul
punctual binar pentru a face formula pentru acțiunea unui strat de gate Hadamard
pe stările bazei standard mai succintă, și iată este chiar acolo.
Folosim faptul că
deoarece această sumă de acolo apare în
exponentul lui -1,
tot ce contează este dacă
este pară sau impară, dar altfel, este practic doar o versiune condensată
a formulei noastre.
Apropo, produsul
punctual binar este simetric în sensul că x punct
y și y punct x sunt egale,
deci suntem liberi să schimbăm
ordinea ori de câte ori este util.
Și acum că avem acea formulă, va fi destul de ușor să analizăm
circuit-ul Deutsch-Jozsa.
Începem cu n qubits în starea 0 și qubit-ul de jos în starea 1, și efectuăm gate-uri Hadamard
pe toți.
Deci aceasta este starea
celor n + 1 qubits pe care o obținem.
Tratăm
qubit-ul de jos separat deoarece asta va fi convenabil.
Și din nou, vom vedea
fenomenul phase kickback producându-se.
WEBVTT
Putem obține această expresie
folosind formula noastră, unde substituim șirul format numai din zerouri cu x și substituim x cu y,
observând că produsul
punctual binar al șirului format numai din zerouri cu orice șir este 0.
Dar putem, de asemenea, să raționăm direct. Luăm produsul tensorial al n stări plus, și asta este ceea ce obținem,
tensorial cu starea minus. Apoi gate-ul UF este aplicat, și iată unde se produce fenomenul
phase kickback.
Valoarea f(x) este aplicată XOR
pe starea minus pentru fiecare x din sumă.
Deci f(x) este retras în fază.
Acum aplicăm un alt
strat de gate-uri Hadamard doar pe primele n qubits, și de data aceasta, chiar avem
nevoie de formulă.
Și când o aplicăm și facem un pic
de simplificare, obținem această stare chiar acolo.
Deci aceasta este starea noastră finală chiar
înainte de măsurători.
Starea arată un pic complicat, și este dificil să o simplificăm deoarece nu știm cu adevărat
nimic despre funcția f.
Dar ține minte, tot ce
avem cu adevărat nevoie să știm este dacă sau nu măsurătorile
toate dau rezultatul 0,
deoarece asta este ceea ce determină care este răspunsul nostru la problemă.
Dacă vedem că fiecare
rezultat al măsurătorii este 0, concluzionăm că funcția este constantă.
Și dacă oricare dintre
rezultatele măsurătorii este 1, concluzionăm că funcția este echilibrată.
Deci să calculăm probabilitatea de a obține șirul format numai din zerouri
din măsurători.
Și se dovedește că acesta este singurul rezultat care este de fapt ușor de calculat, deoarece produsul
punctual binar al șirului format numai din zerouri
cu orice șir este zero. Dacă examinăm vectorul nostru și
ne gândim la ce se întâmplă când y este șirul format numai din zerouri,
obținem această expresie chiar
acolo pentru probabilitatea de a obține șirul format numai din zerouri
din măsurători.
Și considerând cele două cazuri posibile unde f este constantă și f este echilibrată, vedem că probabilitatea de a
obține șirul format numai din zerouri este 1
în cazul în care f este constantă, și zero când f este echilibrată.
Când f este constantă, suma este fie 2 la puterea
n, fie -2 la puterea n, și împărțind la 2 la puterea n
și luând valoarea absolută
la pătrat dă 1.
Și când f este echilibrată, suma este egală cu 0.
Asta deoarece vom obține
+1 și -1 de un număr egal de ori,
deci toate se anulează.
Deci cam atât. Algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa
rezolvă problema Deutsch-Jozsa folosind o singură interogare,
și nu există erori. Presupunând că operațiile
sunt toate efectuate perfect, este corect de fiecare dată.
Deci cum se compară asta cu
ce putem face clasic?
Ei bine, dacă insistăm pe un
algoritm determinist care obține răspunsul
corect de fiecare dată, atunci în cel mai rău caz,
avem nevoie de 2 la puterea n minus 1 plus 1 interogări, și asta deoarece trebuie să interogăm funcția
pe mai mult de jumătate din inputuri pentru a fi siguri cu privire la soluție.
Chiar dacă interogăm funcția pe 2 la puterea n minus 1
șiruri de input diferite, este posibil să vedem aceeași valoare de output
de fiecare dată, și asta ar putea fi deoarece
funcția este constantă, sau ar putea fi că este de fapt echilibrată
și am fost pur și simplu incredibil de ghinionoși că am văzut aceeași valoare de output
de fiecare dată.
Deci acesta este un avantaj enorm
al cuanticului față de clasic, o singură interogare față de
exponențial de multe interogări.
Totuși, dacă folosim un
algoritm cu interogări probabilist și acceptăm o mică probabilitate că răspunde incorect,
atunci avem nevoie de fapt de doar câteva interogări.
Mai concret, dacă
alegem aleatoriu k șiruri și evaluăm funcția
pe acele șiruri aleatorii,
atunci probabil vom putea să aflăm răspunsul corect.
Specific, răspundem 0 sau constant când obținem aceeași valoare a funcției de fiecare dată și 1 sau echilibrat
ori de câte ori vedem două
valori ale funcției diferite.
Dacă facem asta, vom fi întotdeauna corecți când
funcția este constantă deoarece, desigur, vom vedea întotdeauna aceeași
valoare de output în acest caz.
Și dacă f este echilibrată, este foarte probabil să vedem
două valori de output diferite.
Șansa că nu vedem
ambele valori de output în acest caz este aceeași cu șansa de a arunca o monedă de k ori
și a obține același
rezultat de fiecare dată.
Deci de exemplu, dacă
setăm k egal cu 11, probabilitatea de a obține un răspuns greșit este mai mică de o zecime de procent.
Deci mai ales când luăm în considerare faptul că calculatoarele cuantice nu vor fi niciodată perfecte în realitate, nu obținem de fapt un
avantaj atât de mare aici,
dar facem progrese, și avem un avantaj cuantificabil al cuanticului față de clasic care depășește algoritmul lui Deutsch.
Putem folosi, de asemenea, circuit-ul Deutsch-Jozsa pentru a rezolva o altă problemă cu interogări cunoscutî ca problema Bernstein-Vazirani.
Iată o declarație a acestei probleme. Inputul este o funcție
de la n biți la 1 bit, la fel ca problema Deutsch-Jozsa,
WEBVTT
și din nou, este o problemă cu promisiune.
De data aceasta, promisiunea este că există un șir s de n biți pentru care funcția f
funcționează cum îl vezi chiar acolo,
unde outputul este dat
de produsul punctual binar al inputului cu acest șir s,
și scopul este pur și simplu
să găsești șirul s. Deci ne putem imagina că
șirul s este ascuns în anumit sens,
dar putem afla despre el
făcând interogări la f, iar scopul nostru este să găsim
acest șir ascuns.
Pentru a fi clar, majoritatea funcțiilor
nu vor satisface această promisiune, dar ca de obicei, ne interesează doar
funcțiile de input care o fac.
Se dovedește că circuit-ul Deutsch-Jozsa rezolvă de fapt această problemă
direct din start.
Dacă îl rulăm pentru o
funcție ca aceea pe care o avem aici, care satisface
promisiunea pentru un anumit șir s, măsurătorile vor dezvălui șirul s
fără a fi necesar niciun post-procesare.
Deci să vedem cum funcționează asta.
Am analizat deja
circuit-ul Deutsch-Jozsa, deci putem de fapt pur și simplu
să trecem direct la final.
Iată expresia pe care
o aveam de înainte pentru starea chiar înainte de măsurători, și acea expresie era
validă pentru orice funcție f.
Și acum, dacă substituim
ce ni s-a promis despre funcția f și simplificăm,
obținem starea minus
pentru qubit-ul de jos tensorial cu ket s pentru primii n qubits.
Și deci obținem s când măsurăm.
Există ceva de lucru de făcut pentru a efectua simplificările
pe care le-am arătat, și nu voi trece prin asta în acest video,
dar există mai multe detalii despre asta în conținutul textului pentru această serie, pe care îl poți găsi urmând link-ul în descrierea video-ului,
sau încearcă singur
pentru practică.
Deci ce am găsit este că
circuit-ul Deutsch-Jozsa rezolvă problema Bernstein-Vazirani
cu o singură interogare.
Nu este prea greu să arăți
că orice algoritm clasic, fie determinist
fie probabilist, are nevoie de cel puțin n interogări
pentru a rezolva problema Bernstein-Vazirani din simplul motiv că avem nevoie de n biți de
informație pentru a recupera s,
și fiecare interogare ne dă cel
mult 1 bit de informație.
Deci obținem un alt avantaj al cuanticului față de algoritmii clasici cu interogări, o interogare pentru algoritmii cuantici,
n interogări pentru algoritmii clasici.
Merită să ne luăm un moment pentru a vorbi despre
nomenclatura folosită în contextul acestei probleme și un pic despre istorie.
Oamenii se referă uneori la algoritmul pe care tocmai l-am descris ca algoritmul Bernstein-Vazirani, dar este de fapt doar
circuit-ul Deutsch-Jozsa,
și asta a fost, de fapt, enunțat very clar în lucrarea lui Bernstein și Vazirani.
Deci este un pic ciudat că se numește algoritmul Bernstein-Vazirani deoarece este practic același lucru cu algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa
minus post-procesarea. Bernstein și Vazirani au mers totuși un pas mai departe.
Ei au definit o
versiune recursivă a acestei probleme, unde trebuie practic
să rezolvi instanțe ale problemei Bernstein-Vazirani
pentru a debloca noi instanțe ale problemei care sunt aranjate într-un
tipar complicat de tip arbore.
Este o problemă foarte contrivită, dar ideea este că prin
definirea unei probleme în acest mod, puteau efectiv întinde
separația de una versus n interogări dintre cuantic și clasic.
Și ce au obținut este
primul exemplu cunoscut de un așa-zis avantaj super-polinomial al cuanticului față de algoritmii probabilistici.
Această versiune recursivă a
problemei Bernstein-Vazirani s-a dovedit, de asemenea, mult mai târziu
a fi foarte interesantă în teoria complexității
computaționale din motive diferite.
Oricum, ideea este că
Bernstein și Vazirani merită cu siguranță recunoaștere pentru contribuțiile lor importante,
dar nu are cu adevărat
sens să ne referim la asta ca la algoritmul Bernstein-Vazirani, este practic doar
algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa.
În ultima parte a lecției, vom arunca o privire la un
alt algoritm cuantic cu interogări cunoscut ca algoritmul lui Simon.
Vei vedea o similitudine clară
între acest algoritm și algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa, dar este diferit, și mai important,
dezvăluie un avantaj mult mai puternic al cuanticului față de algoritmii clasici
cu interogări.
Concret, ne dă un
avantaj exponențial demonstrabil al cuanticului față de algoritmii clasici, chiar și față de cei probabilistici.
Problema pe care o rezolvă este un pic artificială, și este greu să ne imaginăm o situație în care rezolvarea acestei
probleme ar fi utilă,
dar a inspirat direct
descoperirea de către Peter Shor a unui algoritm cuantic
pentru factorizarea numerelor întregi,
și asta susține foarte puternic
această idee a modelului cu interogări ca un vas Petri în care ideile algoritmice cuantice
pot fi dezvoltate.
Să începem cu problema cu interogări pe care o rezolvă algoritmul lui Simon, care, cum ai fi putut ghici,
se numește problema lui Simon.
Iată o declarație a problemei, și va trebui să o descompunem pentru a înțelege despre ce este vorba.
Primul lucru de
observat este că de data aceasta, funcția de input f mapează șiruri de n
biți la șiruri de m biți
unde m este un număr întreg pozitiv care nu este egal cu unu în general.
WEBVTT
Este o problemă cu promisiune. Și la fel ca problema Bernstein-Vazirani, promisiunea implică un șir s pe care îl putem privi ca un șir ascuns,
și de asemenea la fel ca
problema Bernstein-Vazirani, scopul este să outputăm
acest șir ascuns s.
Promisiunea este mai
complicată de data aceasta, deci să o decompunem și
să înțelegem ce spune.
Să începem, să o citim pur și simplu. Spune că există un șir s cu lungimea egală cu n
astfel încât o anumită condiție de tipul „dacă"
și „numai dacă" este adevărată pentru toate alegerile de șiruri x și y de n biți.
Concret, trebuie
să fie cazul că f(x) este egal cu f(y) dacă și numai dacă una din
două posibilități se îndeplinește.
Prima posibilitate este că x este egal cu y, iar a doua posibilitate este că luând
SAU-ul exclusiv bit cu bit al lui x
cu șirul ascuns s, obținem Y.
Se dovedește că aceasta este o
promisiune destul de strictă în sensul că majority
funcțiile nu o vor satisface.
Numai funcțiile foarte speciale
satisfac această condiție.
Acum, pentru a înțelege mai bine această promisiune și prin urmare problema în sine, vom considera două cazuri principale.
Primul caz este că s
este șirul format numai din zerouri.
În acest caz, putem simplifica declarația de tipul „dacă"
și „numai dacă" din promisiune deoarece SAU-ul exclusiv bit cu bit al oricărui șir x
cu șirul format numai din zerouri
este pur și simplu șirul x.
Deci condiția se simplifică
la f(x) este egal cu f(y) dacă și numai dacă x este egal cu y.
Și asta este doar un alt mod de a spune că f este o funcție unu la unu.
Cu alte cuvinte, șirul f(x) trebuie să fie unic
pentru fiecare șir x posibil.
Deci dacă f este o funcție unu la unu, atunci promisiunea este într-adevăr satisfăcută, concret pentru s egal cu
șirul format numai din zerouri,
și în acest caz, acesta este
outputul corect.
Al doilea caz este că s
nu este șirul format numai din zerouri, și ceea ce implică asta este că funcția f trebuie să fie doi la unu.
Deci pentru fiecare șir de input x, există exact un alt șir pe care f îl mapează la același
șir la care mapează x,
și mai mult, celălalt șir
trebuie să fie șirul pe care îl obținem luând
SAU-ul exclusiv bit cu bit al lui x cu s.
Un alt mod de a spune asta
este că fiecare șir de n biți x are un partener, iar acel partener este șirul pe care îl obținem
luând SAU-ul exclusiv bit cu bit cu s.
Oricare doi parteneri trebuie să ne
dea același șir de output dacă îi introducem în f, și niciun alt șir nu are voie să ne dea
același șir de output.
Deci acestea sunt în mod necesar șiruri distincte pe care partenerii le produc.
Iată un exemplu de funcție de acest fel descrisă prin tabelul ei de valori.
Deci aceasta este o funcție
de la 3 biți la 5 biți.
Dacă ne uităm la acest tabel
de valori un timp, găsim că promisiunea este
satisfăcută pentru șirul 011.
000 și 011 sunt parteneri. Aplicând XOR oricăruia dintre ei
cu s ne dă pe celălalt,
și au aceeași valoare de output, care este 10011 în acest caz particular, și niciun alt șir nu produce
acel același șir de output.
001 și 010 sunt parteneri deoarece aplicând XOR oricăruia
cu s dă pe celălalt, și produc aceeași valoare de output,
care, din nou, nu este produsă
de niciun alt șir.
Și situația este
similară pentru 100 și 111, precum și pentru 101 și 110.
Deci dacă inputul pentru
problemă este această funcție, răspunsul corect este șirul 011.
Cum am spus înainte, majority funcțiilor nu satisfac această promisiune, este o condiție foarte specifică.
Ar trebui, de asemenea, notat că
dacă promisiunea este satisfăcută, ea poate fi satisfăcută doar pentru un singur șir s.
Deci există întotdeauna un singur
răspuns corect la această problemă.
Deci aceasta este problema lui Simon. Cum am spus, este greu să ne imaginăm o situație practică în care ai dori să rezolvi această problemă,
dar nu asta contează. Ideea este să încerci să afli ce sunt bune calculatoarele cuantice, și se dovedește că sunt cu mult superioare
algoritmilor clasici pentru
rezolvarea acestei probleme particulare.
Acum să aruncăm o privire
la algoritmul lui Simon, care rezolvă problema lui Simon.
Algoritmul constă în
rularea quantum circuit-ului pe care îl vezi aici de mai multe ori, urmată de un
pas de post-procesare clasic,
și vom fi mai specifici despre ce înseamnă de mai multe ori
un pic mai târziu.
Circuit-ul arată foarte similar
cu circuit-ul Deutsch-Jozsa, de data aceasta deoarece funcția
f mapează n biți la m biți,
gate-ul de interogare este diferit. Mai degrabă decât un singur
qubit în jos, avem acum m qubits în jos
și n în sus ca înainte.
O diferență cheie este că nu
configurăm o stare minus sau mai multe stări minus în jos.
Acești qubits de jos sunt toți
inițializați la starea 0, și acele stări intră direct
în gate-ul de interogare.
WEBVTT
Deci nu va exista niciun phase kickback implicat în acest algoritm, pur și simplu nu este cum funcționează acesta.
Cu excepția diferențelor
pe care le-am menționat, arată foarte similar cu
circuit-ul Deutsch-Jozsa.
Aplicăm un strat de gate-uri Hadamard, apoi aplicăm un gate de interogare o singură dată, și apoi aplicăm un alt
strat de gate-uri Hadamard
urmată de măsurători ale bazei standard ale primilor n qubits.
Ideea este că de fiecare dată când
rulăm acest circuit și măsurăm, vom obține un șir y care ne spune ceva
despre șirul ascuns s
în problema lui Simon. Și rulând circuit-ul
de mai multe ori în mod independent, vom fi adunat suficiente
dovezi statistice despre s
pentru a putea afla ce
este cu o încredere ridicată.
Acum să analizăm quantum circuit-ul
pentru algoritmul lui Simon pentru a vedea ce face.
Starea după primul
strat de gate-uri Hadamard arată astfel, similar cu ce am avut pentru
algoritmul Deutsch-Jozsa.
Cu excepția că de data aceasta, cei m qubits de jos sunt toți în starea 0
mai degrabă decât în stări minus.
După ce gate-ul de interogare este efectuat, vedem că valoarea f(x) a fost scrisă pe
ultimii sau cei mai din stânga m qubits,
și asta deoarece f(x) a fost aplicat XOR pe șirul format numai din zerouri.
Deci din nou, nu există phase kickback care se produce în acest algoritm.
Efectuăm apoi al doilea
strat de gate-uri Hadamard.
Și folosind aceeași formulă ca înainte pentru acțiunea unui
strat de gate-uri Hadamard pe o stare a bazei standard,
ket x în acest caz,
cum era în formula originală, obținem această stare chiar acolo, unde acțiunea gate-urilor Hadamard
a fost făcută mai evidentă. Dar dacă vrem, putem de asemenea scrie starea
într-o formă mai compactă cum avem chiar acolo.
În acest punct, măsurăm primii n qubits pentru a obține un șir y de n biți, și trebuie doar să aflăm
care sunt probabilitățile
pentru diferitele șiruri. Și asta ne va ajuta să înțelegem
ce informație obținem din acest șir y despre șirul s
care este ascuns în interiorul funcției f.
Vom avea nevoie de
mai mult spațiu pentru asta, și nu mai avem nevoie de
diagrama circuit-ului, deci să scăpăm de ea și să ne dăm mai mult spațiu pentru analiză.
Iată starea chiar
înainte de măsurători, care sunt măsurători ale bazei standard ale primilor sau cei mai din dreapta n qubits.
Deci măsurătoarea
corespunde celui de-al doilea ket.
Să notăm cu p(y), probabilitatea ca măsurătorile să ne dea șirul y pentru fiecare y posibil.
Și dacă urmăm regulile din Lecția 2, obținem că fiecare dintre aceste probabilități este norma euclidiană la pătrat a oricărui vector tensorial
corespunzând lui why în
vectorul nostru de stare cuantică.
Asta ne dă această expresie chiar acolo.
Acum, pentru a înțelege mai bine
aceste probabilități, va trebui să
folosim niște notații, și s-ar putea să fii deja familiarizat cu această notație
deoarece este destul de comună în matematică.
Mai întâi, când ne referim la
imaginea funcției f, înțelegem pur și simplu mulțimea tuturor șirurilor care pot ieși din această funcție.
Deci este mulțimea tuturor f(x) pentru toate alegerile posibile
ale unui șir de input x.
În al doilea rând, vom folosi această notație pe care o vezi chiar acolo pentru a însemna mulțimea tuturor șirurilor de input x
pe care f le mapează la un șir dat z, pentru orice alegere
a lui z pe care vrem să o considerăm.
Arată un pic ca
inversul funcției f, dar nu este cu adevărat inversul deoarece f nu este neapărat inversabilă.
Vedem, de asemenea, că avem
o mulțime ca argument în partea stângă, iar în acest caz, este mulțimea conținând
un singur șir z,
și asta este indiciul de care avem nevoie pentru a recunoaște că nu vorbim despre
inversul funcției f, aceasta se numește pre-imaginea.
Pre-imaginea poate fi
definită mai general pentru orice mulțime dată ca argument, nu doar mulțimea conținând
un singur element,
dar asta este tot ce vom
folosi. Nu este cea mai bună
notație din lume deoarece este ușor să
o confunzi cu inversul,
dar este suficient de clară
și este utilizată pe scară largă, deci vom merge cu ea.
Și acum dacă folosim această notație, putem rescrie vectorul de care luăm norma euclidiană la pătrat pentru a obține probabilitatea pentru
măsurarea fiecărui șir y.
Facem asta deoarece trebuie să vedem
care sunt coeficienții pentru fiecare stare individuală a bazei standard, și nu este clar din
această expresie de acolo,
deoarece, în general, putem
avea mai multe alegeri ale lui x care ne dau același șir f(x).
În esență, tot ce facem
este să împărțim suma peste x sumând mai întâi peste tot
z în imaginea lui f,
și apoi în interiorul acelei sume, sumând peste toți x din pre-imaginea lui z, sau mai precis,
pre-imaginea mulțimii
care conține șirul z.
Asta ne permite să înlocuim f(x) cu z în interiorul ket-ului de acolo.
Și suma peste toate diferitele șiruri
x pe care f le mapează la fiecare z sunt adunate în coeficientul
pentru fiecare ket.
Practic, punem șiruri în coșuri, sumăm peste coșuri, și apoi sumăm peste
șirurile din fiecare coș,
WEBVTT
dar asta este echivalent cu a
suma pur și simplu peste toate șirurile.
Deci obținem o expresie care este echivalentă cu
cea cu care am început,
și acum putem calcula
norma euclidiană la pătrat.
Este pur și simplu suma pătratelor valorilor absolute
ale coeficienților, și deci obținem această expresie de acolo
pentru probabilitățile noastre.
Desigur, dă-ți
timp să verifici asta, dacă alegi să o faci, este nevoie de timp pentru a te obișnui cu toate acestea
și pentru a putea efectua
aceste calcule, și cu cât practici mai mult, cu atât va deveni mai ușor.
Până acum, nu am folosit de fapt
promisiunea din problema lui Simon deloc.
Analiza noastră a acestor probabilități funcționează de fapt pentru orice funcție f, dar acum este momentul să ne gândim specific la
problema lui Simon.
Vom descompune lucrurile în aceleași două cazuri
pe care le-am avut înainte.
Primul caz este că s
este șirul format numai din zerouri, iar al doilea caz este că
s nu este șirul format numai din zerouri.
În primul caz, că
s este șirul format numai din zerouri, lucrurile sunt destul de simple.
În acest caz, cum am văzut înainte, avem că f este o funcție unu la unu, deci există un singur șir x
care este mapat la fiecare dintre
șirurile z din imaginea lui f.
Asta face ca valoarea absolută la pătrat a sumei peste acele șiruri să fie egală cu 1 deoarece există doar un
singur termen în sumă,
este fie +1 fie -1, dar nu contează care deoarece luăm
valoarea absolută la pătrat, și deci obținem unu.
Există 2 la puterea n
elemente în imaginea lui f, și știm asta deoarece f este unu la unu, deci există un șir în
imagine pentru fiecare șir de input.
Și dacă evaluăm întreaga expresie, găsim că fiecare șir y apare cu probabilitatea
1 împărțit la 2 la puterea n.
Deci cu alte cuvinte,
măsurătorile ne dau un șir y ales uniform la întâmplare.
Asta s-ar putea să nu pară chiar atât de util, dar vom putea, de fapt,
să distingem acest comportament de comportamentul pe care îl obținem în cazul
că s nu este șirul format numai din zerouri, și vom vedea cum merge asta în scurt timp.
Deocamdată, observăm pur și simplu că dacă
f satisface promisiunea în problema lui Simon în cazul că s este șirul format numai din zerouri,
atunci rezultatul măsurătorilor este un șir aleatoriu uniform.
Acum să trecem la al doilea caz, care este că promisiunea
este satisfăcută pentru un șir s care nu este șirul format numai din zerouri.
În acest caz, cum am discutat înainte, fiecare șir z din imaginea lui f are exact două șiruri care îl mapează,
deoarece fiecare șir are un partener, și fiecare pereche de parteneri
mapează la un șir unic, și concret, partenerul fiecărui șir
este șirul pe care îl obținem aplicând XOR cu s.
Deci dacă alegem orice șir
z din imaginea lui f, și dăm numele w oricăruia dintre
șirurile pe care f le mapează la z,
atunci XOR-ul lui w cu s este
celălalt șir care mapează la z.
Privind doar termenul din suma noastră care corespunde oricărui șir z din imagine pe care îl avem în minte,
vedem că putem
să-l scriem mai explicit cum avem chiar acolo.
Avem două șiruri în pre-imaginea lui z, w și w XOR s.
Deci putem scrie suma
cum îl vezi pe ecran, și acum ce putem face este să scoatem un factor de
-1 la puterea w.y.
Acel factor va fi
fie +1 fie -1, deci dispare când
luăm valoarea absolută,
și ce rămâne este
această expresie chiar acolo.
Detaliile nu sunt toate arătate acolo, și nu este neapărat
evident că funcționează astfel, dar poți verifica că aceste
două expresii sunt egale
revenind la definiția
produsului punctual binar și gândindu-te la ce se întâmplă când aceste lucruri sunt în
exponentul lui -1,
nu altfel decât ce am avut pentru
problema Bernstein-Vazirani.
În final, putem descompune această
expresie în două cazuri.
Este 4 când produsul
punctual binar al lui s și y este 0, și este 0 când produsul
punctual binar al lui s și y este 1.
Observă în particular că
nu există nicio dependență deloc de w sau z, depinde doar de s și y.
Motivul pentru care se întâmplă asta este
din cauza naturii foarte specifice și speciale a promisiunii.
În esență, de aceea a fost formulată promisiunea în acest mod, astfel încât totul să se potrivească astfel.
Din nou, fiecare șir are un partener, pe care îl obținem aplicând XOR cu
acest singur șir ascuns s,
și asta este ceea ce face ca toate acestea să se întâmple.
Putem acum să ne întoarcem la
expresia pentru probabilități și să introducem valorile.
Când s nu este șirul format numai din zerouri, există 2 la puterea n minus 1
elemente în imaginea lui f,
care este jumătate din
numărul de șiruri de input, și introducând
valorile pe care le-am calculat adineauri ne dă această formulă chiar acolo.
Deci de data aceasta, y nu este un
șir complet aleatoriu, ci mai degrabă y este uniform peste exact jumătate din șirurile de n biți,
WEBVTT
și concret, este
uniform peste acele șiruri care au produsul
punctual binar egal cu 0 cu s.
Acum că știm cum funcționează circuit-ul
pentru algoritmul lui Simon și concret care
sunt probabilitățile pentru diferitele rezultate ale măsurătorilor,
rămâne de explicat cum ne ajută asta să rezolvăm problema lui Simon.
Rezumând ce am aflat tocmai, dacă funcția f satisface promisiunea în problema lui Simon,
când șirul ascuns s
este șirul format numai din zerouri, obținem un șir complet aleatoriu din măsurători,
unde fiecare șir y de n biți
este la fel de probabil.
Dacă pe de altă parte, funcția f satisface promisiunea pentru un șir s diferit, unul care nu este egal
cu șirul format numai din zerouri,
atunci obținem un șir aleatoriu y cu produsul
punctual binar egal cu 0 cu s, și dintre toate acele șiruri,
fiecare y este la fel de probabil.
Dar nu vom obține niciodată un șir y cu produsul
punctual binar egal cu 1 cu s.
Întrebarea devine: „Este aceasta suficientă informație
pentru a determina s?" Și răspunsul, cum am
sugerat deja, este da,
cu condiția că rulăm
circuit-ul suficient de multe ori.
Concret, să presupunem
că rulăm circuit-ul de k ori, unde K este egal cu n plus r,
unde r este un număr care va controla
probabilitatea că recuperăm s.
De exemplu, dacă
alegem r egal cu 10, vom reuși cu
probabilitate mai mare de 99.9%,
deci nu avem nevoie ca r să fie chiar atât de mare.
În general, probabilitatea de eșec este mai mică decât probabilitatea
de a arunca o monedă corectă de r ori și a obține cap de fiecare dată.
Deci dacă 99.9% nu este suficient de bun
atunci ia r egal cu 20, iar șansa de eșec este
mai mică de unu dintr-un milion,
sau alege orice r
te face să te simți confortabil. Nu poți garanta o soluție corectă, dar poți face
probabilitatea de eroare neglijabilă
în toate scopurile practice.
Iată numim aceste
șiruri y1 până la yk, unde folosim superscripturi pentru a ne ajuta să numim aceste șiruri,
doar ca să putem rezerva subscripturile pentru a ne referi la biții individuali
ai acelor șiruri.
Deci acestea nu sunt exponentele
sau ceva de genul ăsta, acestea sunt pur și simplu numele pe care le dăm acestor k șiruri.
Fiecare are lungimea n deoarece le-am obținut
rulând circuit-ul pentru algoritmul lui Simon.
Deci putem scrie
biții individuali ai acestor k șiruri cum îi vezi chiar acolo.
Ce facem acum este să creăm o matrice m, unde fiecare intrare a acestei matrice este un bit, iar noi obținem acești biți din șirurile
pe care tocmai le-am măsurat, exact cum este arătat acolo.
Deci această matrice are k rânduri și n coloane, iar intrările sale sunt toate valori binare.
Acum, nu știm ce este s. Asta este ceea ce încercăm să găsim, dar imaginează-ți pentru un
moment că am ști s,
și am forma un vector
coloană din biții lui s, exact cum este arătat chiar acolo.
Dacă am înmulți acel vector cu m și apoi am lua rezultatul modulo 2, sau un alt mod de a spune asta
este că înlocuim adunarea
cu SAU exclusiv, atunci vom obține în mod necesar
vectorul format numai din zerouri.
Asta deoarece fiecare dintre
intrările în acest vector rezultant nu este altceva decât produsul
punctual binar al lui s
cu unul dintre rândurile lui m.
Dacă S se întâmplă să fie șirul format numai din zerouri, vom obține întotdeauna vectorul zero din produsul punctual binar.
Și dacă s nu este șirul format numai din zerouri, vom obține asta din ce
știm despre probabilitățile pentru șirurile y1 până la yk să apară.
Concret, produsul
punctual binar cu s este întotdeauna zero pentru toate aceste șiruri.
Un mod simplu de a spune asta este că acest vector
format din biții lui s este întotdeauna în spațiul nul
al matricei m,
presupunând că facem toată
aritmetica noastră modulo 2, dar desigur, nu știm ce este s,
încercăm să găsim s.
Dar ce putem face este să calculăm
spațiul nul al acestei matrice m, din nou, modulo 2.
Concret, putem face asta folosind tehnica
eliminării Gaussiene, care este procedura care este adesea predată
în cursurile introductive de algebră liniară.
Funcționează perfect când facem toată aritmetica noastră modulo 2, și poate fi efectuată destul de
eficient cu un calculator.
Și dacă calculăm spațiul nul al lui m, dat modul specific în care aceste k șiruri au
fost alese aleatoriu,
vom putea recupera s cu probabilitate mai mare de
1 minus 2 la puterea negativă r.
Să fim specifici, ceea ce vom vedea cu probabilitate mai mare de
1 minus 2 la puterea negativă r este că spațiul nul
include vectorul format numai din zerouri,
cum face întotdeauna pentru orice matrice, precum și vectorul corespunzând lui s, fie că este vectorul format numai din zerouri sau nu.
Și cel mai important, niciun alt vector nu va
apărea în spațiul nul.
De fapt, nu este prea greu să dovedești asta, deși nu voi trece prin detalii.
WEBVTT
Ideea este că dacă
avem un alt șir care nu este vectorul format numai din zerouri
și nu este s, atunci fiecare dintre șirurile aleatorii, y1 până la yk,
va scoate practic
din spațiul nul cu probabilitate jumătate.
Deci după k rulări, nu este
deloc probabil să supraviețuiască, și de fapt, niciunul dintre
șirurile care nu aparțin
nu este probabil să supraviețuiască. Și un fapt foarte simplu
din teoria probabilităților, cunoscut ca legătura uniunii, poate
fi folosit pentru a stabili asta.
Nu am explicat toate
detaliile aici, dar sperăm că înțelegi ideea că calculând spațiul nul
modulo 2 al acestei matrice m,
este foarte probabil să recuperăm s, și cam asta este cum algoritmul lui Simon
rezolvă problema lui Simon.
Mai este un singur lucru de spus
despre problema lui Simon, și se referă la
dificultatea clasică a acestei probleme,
adică, câte interogări are nevoie un algoritm clasic cu interogări pentru a rezolva problema lui Simon?
Răspunsul este, mulțime, în general.
Există diferite declarații precise
care pot fi făcute despre dificultatea clasică a acestei probleme, și iată una dintre ele.
Dacă avem orice
algoritm cu interogări probabilist și acesta face mai puțin de 2 la puterea n peste 2
minus 1, minus 1 interogări,
deci acesta este un număr de interogări
care este exponențial în n, atunci acel algoritm va eșua
să rezolve problema lui Simon,
cu probabilitate cel puțin jumătate.
Uneori, dovedirea
rezultatelor de imposibilitate ca acesta poate fi foarte provocatoare, dar acesta nu este prea dificil de dovedit
printr-o analiză probabilistică
elementară.
Nu voi face asta în această lecție video, și mă voi concentra în schimb
pe intuiția din spatele lui.
Încercăm să găsim șirul ascuns s, dar atât timp cât nu interogăm funcția pe două șiruri cu
aceeași valoare de output,
vom obține informații
foarte limitate despre s.
Practic, tot ce aflăm este
că șirul ascuns s nu este SAU-ul exclusiv al niciunor două șiruri distincte
pe care le-am interogat,
Și dacă interogăm funcția la mai puțin decât acest număr de interogări, vor exista în continuare o mulțime de alegeri ale lui s
care nu au fost excluse.
Aceasta nu este o demonstrație formală,
dar aceasta este ideea de bază.
Deci, în rezumat, algoritmul lui Simon ne oferă un avantaj remarcabil al cuanticului față de algoritmii clasici
în cadrul modelului cu interogări.
Concret, algoritmul lui Simon
rezolvă problema lui Simon cu un număr de interogări care este liniar în numărul de biți de input
n ai funcției noastre,
în timp ce orice algoritm clasic,
chiar dacă este probabilist, trebuie să facă un număr de
interogări care este exponențial în n
pentru a rezolva problema lui Simon cu o probabilitate rezonabilă de succes.
Este adevărat că problema lui Simon este o problemă oarecum artificială pe care se presupune că nimeni
nu vrea cu adevărat să o rezolve,
dar asta este secundar. Uneori, ideile trebuie să fie dezvoltate înainte de a fi puse în practică.
Și într-adevăr, Peter Shor a declarat clar că algoritmul lui Simon l-a inspirat acum
faimosul algoritm cuantic
pentru factorizarea numerelor întregi, pe care îl vom vedea în câteva lecții.
Și aceasta este sfârșitul Lecției 5.
În această lecție, am aruncat o privire la
modelul de calcul cu interogări, și am văzut o progresie de exemple
de algoritmi cuantici
care prezintă avantaje față de algoritmii clasici
în cadrul acestui model.
Există, de fapt, mult mai mult
cunoscut despre modelul cu interogări și algoritmii cuantici pentru alte probleme pe care
nu le-am discutat.
Deci dacă găsești
modelul interesant, există destul de mult
mai mult de învățat despre el.
Pasul nostru următor va fi să ne îndepărtăm
de la modelul cu interogări spre un model de calcul
mai reprezentativ
pentru tipurile de probleme pe care sperăm să le rezolvăm în practică.
Sper că te vei alătura mie pentru Lecția 6, unde ne vom concentra în principal pe
stabilirea unui fundament pentru studierea algoritmilor cuantici.
Și de acolo, vom trece la unii
algoritmi cuantici specifici, inclusiv algoritmul lui Shor
pentru factorizarea numerelor întregi
în lecțiile ulterioare. La revedere până atunci!